community we're partnering with
albertsons to help gift you a good day
every week we'll be surprising one lucky
shopper and helping pay for their
groceries let's take a look at how i
surprised one albertson shopper
[Music]
i met karen at the albertsons in east
las vegas she said she lives in a
different part of town but comes to this
location because she loves it so much
i used to live on this side of town on
the east side and then i moved on up a
million parkway so you come all the way
here come on we're here to shop she told
me how hard it is to afford things when
rent has gone up so high it is high
a buddhist high rent is off the chain
here we're on social security
and we don't get that much too much
so you know we're it's it's it's it's a
struggle to survive here but she always
keeps her faith
mercy you gotta have god
he's gotta pray you just gotta have god
that's what eight news now and
albertsons decided it was time to gift
karen a good day and help pay for some
of her groceries we'd like to help you
out a little bit and like it to make it
a good day for watch your mouth channel
eight would like to pay for some of your
friends today thank you jesus but thank
you lord thank you i must have come at
the right time huh i've been shopping
here for 17 years my god
thank you
i guess it was this morning thank you
god thank you
karen just so happy so delightful i had
such a good time surprising her and you
never know you could be next keep an eye
out for the good day team
maybe you'll be the next person gifted a
good day we know it helps i just love
how excited folks get her husband was an
absolute riot he was so funny he was
ready for football season that's all he
wanted to talk about and get out of the
grocery store
and it's funny because the way we you
know when we encounter folks in the
grocery line i think the people behind
them in line like like her husband being
like wow gee look at the time well we
really got to get a thing oh wait you're
getting this money that someone's
talking to somebody from tv
yeah it's time to go or the or
can i get it too yeah oh yeah and then
we pull out the fake credit card and
everything is a little bit better though
i love the giant thing yeah that's
awesome yeah it's fake until the cashier
takes it and rings it up for your
groceries
but it's not fake
very fun thing i love doing it